do you miss me a smoke i do  100  and  i do and it's one of those things that i  got it i got the opportunity to go back  and and pick her up again on the flash  last year they did this big armageddon  event where they brought in a bunch of  fun characters as the world was ending  as it always is somewhere in the cw  verse  and it was actually quite emotional um  because you know green arrow was one of  the last jobs i did before the pandemic  um barring the stand and a few other  things  and getting to go back to the you know  vancouver film studios and put on the  suit again and it was such kind of a  bookmark of it felt like home and it was  the first time that in two and a half  years of  abnormal and weird and unknown  environment that we'd all been living in  i just felt normal again